Новини дня «heute» з Барбарою Гальвег.
Доброго вечора. Ласкаво просимо до
огляду новин цієї п'ятниці.
Новини спорту традиційно розповість Норберт Кеніґ.
Добрий вечір.
Сьогодні у випуску:
Шлях до Європейського Союзу -
Єврокомісія рекомендує надати статус кандидата
в ЄС Україні та Молдові.
Газу може не вистачити - дебати про
енергоощадливість набирають нових обертів.
Обговорюється можливість ухвалення
відповідних законів.
Підготовка до шаленої спеки -
завтра в деяких регіонах Німеччини очікуються
рекордно високі температури.
На членство в ЄС Україні
доведеться чекати кілька років.
Стовідсоткових гарантій вступу немає.
Та незважаючи на це, сьогодні надзвичайно
важливий день для країни, в якій триває війна:
Єврокомісія рекомендувала країнам-учасницям
надати статус кандидата в ЄС Україні та Молдові.
Іна Д'Ондт розповість більше.
Єврокомісія надсилає з Брюсселя чіткий сигнал
солідарності з Україною,
ухваливши важливе рішення за досить
складних обставин.
Так, Україна заслуговує на перспективу
європейського майбутнього.
І оскільки Україна вже доклала великих зусиль,
ми маємо винагородити її старання, надавши
офіційний статус кандидата на вступ до ЄС.
Проте попереду все ще велика кількість роботи.
Президент України Володимир Зеленський
подякував Єврокомісії у Twitter,
зазначивши, що це «історичне рішення».
Не останню роль в ухваленні рішення відіграли
очільники європейських країн,
які вчора разом із канцлером Шольцом
відвідали Ірпінь та Київ.
Серед основних вимог комісії до України -
активна боротьба з корупцією.
Як зазначає директор Transparency International в
Україні, у цій справі вже було досягнено великих успіхів.
Додаткові вимоги до уряду - це позитивний момент,
який полегшить нашу роботу,
оскільки ми матимемо більше аргументів
для посилення боротьби з корупцією в країні.
Єврокомісія також рекомендує
надати статус кандидата на вступ до Євросоюзу
Республіці Молдові. Таким чином обидві країни
нарешті потрапили до так званого списку очікування.
Тепер необхідно переконати країни, які
не були в захваті від такого рішення.
Наприклад, Нідерланди, які рішуче виступили
проти привілеїв для України.
Ми побоювалися радикальних рішень Єврокомісії,
однак, на щастя, їй вдалося знайти золоту середину.
Було обрано компромісне рішення,
яке ми згодні підтримати.
Наступного тижня очільники країн та урядів
мають ухвалити одностайне рішення
про підтримку або ж
заперечення пропозиції Єврокомісії.
З нами на зв'язку з Брюсселя Гуннар Крюґер.
Які побоювання викликає в європейців надання
Україні статусу кандидата на вступ до ЄС
і чому попри всі перестороги очікується, що
на саміті наступного тижня
всі країни одностайно
підтримають рішення Єврокомісії?
Якщо коротко,
справа в тому, що Єврокомісія встановила певну ціну
рішення, яка вочевидь виявилася зависокою для критиків.
Україна має виконати 7 основних вимог.
Передусім йдеться про впровадження
вже наявних законів,
наприклад, про швидке призначення прокурорів,
які мають боротися з корупцією в країні.
Жовто-блакитний одяг Урсули фон дер Ляєн
став важливим меседжем для Європи.
Таким чином, вона чітко дала зрозуміти послідовність:
спершу статус кандидата, а вже потім реформи.
Такі країни, як Данія та Нідерланди мали
іншу позицію щодо цієї ситуації.
Сьогодні ж обидві країни вирішили, що не хочуть
заважати втіленню головної мрії українців.
Не вдалося переконати лише Австрію, на думку якої,
наразі варто зосередити більше уваги на
балканських країнах, які вже довгий час висловлюють
своє бажання стати членами Європейського Союзу.
Як ми знаємо, досить непередбачуваною країною є
Угорщина, яка теж в будь-яку мить може висловити свою незгоду.
Але Ви маєте рацію, Барбаро,
рішення про надання Україні статусу кандидата на
вступ - це більше, ніж просто припущення.
Наступного тижня 27 очільників держав та урядів
скажуть «так» наданню Україні статусу
кандидата на вступ до Європейського Союзу.
Дякуємо за інформацію.
З нами був Гуннар Крюґер з Брюсселю.
Якою ж буде реакція Росії?
«Ми не проти вступу України в ЄС» -
сказав сьогодні президент Путін,
різко розкритикувавши Захід водночас.
На економічному форумі в Санкт-Петербурзі Путін
звинуватив США в бажанні колонізувати інші країни.
Крім того, він зазначив, що західні санкції
виявилися не ефективними.
Спроби ослабити російську економіку провалилися.
Росія постачає дедалі менше газу до Німеччини.
Німецькі газосховища заповнені лише наполовину.
Федеральне мережеве агентство з електроенергії,
газу, телекомунікацій, пошти та залізниць
повідомляє, що наразі газопостачання в країні
здійснюється стабільно,
однак сьогодні вперше пролунала заява про те,
що ситуація з енергоносіями насправді складна.
Було висунуто пропозицію заощадження газу,
тобто контролю опалення.
Раніше домовласники повинні були регулювати систему
опалення таким чином,
щоб житлові приміщення протягом дня нагрівалися
до 20 градусів.
Наразі тривають дискусії щодо зниження цільового
показника до 18 градусів.
Критики вже назвали подібні ініціативи
«неприйнятними» та «безглуздими».
Карл Гінтерляйтнер розповість більше.
Відрегулювати опалення в квартирі та менше
користуватися автівкою - кожен може зробити свій
добровільний внесок для заощадження енергії.
Проте, якщо газу виявиться обмаль,
таких дій буде недостатньо.
Гарантовані законом 20 градусів у будинках
звичайних німців доведеться зменшити, -
попереджають представники житлових компаній.
У крайньому випадку нестачі газу, який став би
справжньою енергетичною катастрофою для
Німеччини, ми б запропонували знизити
стандартний температурний показник на 2 позначки.
Об'єднання орендарів не підтримують таку ідею.
Вони вважають втручання держави недоречним, а
також запевняють, що найбільше таке рішення
нашкодить звичайним громадянам.
Ми негативно оцінюємо встановлені
державою теплові ліміти.
Але ми переконані, що подібні рішення нехтують
інтересами звичайних людей,
зокрема, людей літнього віку або людей з
серйозними захворюваннями,
які потребують дещо вищих
температурних показників, ніж інші групи населення.
Це лише план Б на випадок, якщо запасів газу
не вистачатиме на зиму.
У такому разі держава повинна
запровадити режим жорсткої економії енергії.
Заощаджуймо енергію вже зараз,
заощаджуймо газ вже зараз
для того, щоб втримати енергетичну
незалежність нашої країни.
Я звертаюся як до великих підприємств, так і до
звичайних громадян.
Ми маємо ретельно проаналізувати ситуацію.
Якщо наші запаси не збільшаться,
ми будемо вимушені вжити додаткових заходів
із метою енергозаощадження,
а в крайньому разі - закріпити нові обмеження
на законодавчому рівні.
Поки що невідомо, чи набудуть чинності
нові законодавчі обмеження.
Це залежить, зокрема, від того, чи перекриє
Росія свій газовий кран.
Матіас Форнофф повідомляє про неочікувані
результати опитування «Політбарометра».
Доброго вечора. Розпочнімо з політики федерального
уряду стосовно України. Як народ оцінює дії уряду?
Дехто вважає дії уряду недостатніми за швидкістю
та обсягами.
Проте більшість респондентів «Політбарометра»
мають протилежну точку зору.
43 відсотки опитаних повністю підтримують дії уряду.
33 відсотки вважають дії уряду недостатніми.
І лише 16 відсотків респондентів переконані,
що підтримка України нашим урядом є надто великою.
Захід вже почав постачання
важкого озброєння для України
і планує робити це надалі.
Чи допоможе це Україні перемогти війну?
У цьому переконаний кожен четвертий.
Проте більшість опитаних, а саме 64 відсотки,
не вірять у те, що Україні вдасться перемогти Росію.
Через війну в Україні стрімко
зросли ціни на енергоносії.
Щоб бодай трішки пом'якшити наслідки такого
здорожчання, було введено в обіг
пільговий квиток за 9 євро.
Та чи приніс він очікуваних результатів?
Ще б пак.
Результати добре видно на цьому графіку.
Так, майже три чверті респондентів позитивно оцінили
можливість користування квитком за 9 євро влітку.
80 відсотків опитаних сумніваються, що громадяни інтенсивно
користуватимуться автобусами та потягами тривалий час.
Погляньмо на співвідношення сил між партіями.
Якби в неділю відбулися вибори до Бундестагу,
SPD отримала б 22 відсотки голосів,
CDU - 26, тобто суттєвих розбіжностей з
реальним станом речей не спостерігаємо.
Партія Зелених набрала б 25 відсотків голосів
(на 1 відсоток більше), FDP - 6 (на 1 відсоток менше),
AfD знову здобула б 10 відсотків,
а партія Лівих - 5 (на 1 відсоток більше).
Таким чином, CDU та партія Зелених залишили б
далеко позаду SPD та, особливо, FDP .
Дякую, Матіасе.
Стає дедалі цікавіше.
Детальніше ознайомитися з результатами опитування
«Політбарометра» ви зможете
у вечірньому випуску «heute journal» о 22 годині.
Хто ж очолить AfD?
На з'їзді мають обрати до неділі нового очільника
федерального правління партії
у зв'язку з відставкою співголови Йорґа Мойтена.
Це загрожує глибоко розділеній партії боротьбою
за владу та суперечками стосовно нового курсу.
Зрозуміло одне: після серії поразок на виборах, настрій
в партії ймовірно буде пригніченим.
Так, на виборах до Бундестагу партія
втратила 2, 3 відсотки голосів.
Невтішними виявилися і результати парламентських
виборів: втрата виборців у землі Саар,
мінус 2 відсотки голосів
у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії,
а в Шлезвіг-Гольштейні AfD взагалі
не потрапила до парламенту.
Про вирішальні дні виборів у саксонському
містечку Різа - Крістіана Гюбшер.
Справи Тіно Крупалли невтішні.
Через два з половиною роки очолювання AfD
Крупалла спостерігає сильні внутрішні конфлікти в партії.
Доленосні вихідні з 600 делегатами.
Сьогодні ми хочемо залишити
позаду деструктивні настрої.
На цьому з'їзді ми маємо обрати очільника
федерального правління,
який керуватиметься принципом колегіальності,
ухвалюватиме конструктивні рішення,
викликатиме довіру свого електорату та послідовно
дотримуватиметься обраної стратегії.
Досвід AfD з двовладдям
складно назвати позитивним.
Майже кожен владний тандем
розпадався передчасно.
Що ж, настав час вийти з тіні.
Я прихильник одноосібного очолювання правління.
Це означає керівництво в умовах свободи та
відповідальності протягом певного проміжку часу.
70% присутніх представників партії AfD згідні із заявою Хоке.
У майбутньому може бути один чи два очільники -
успіх для суперечливого лідера Тюрингії,
якого управління із захисту конституції
підозрює в правому екстремізмі.
Цього разу Хоке, ймовірно не стане, очільником.
Але Крупалла хоче продовжити очільництво,
і якщо вдвох,
тоді бажано з Аліс Вайдель, яка все ще вагається.
Я не виключаю цього.
Залежить від кандидатів, які теж хочуть.
Ще принаймні двоє охочих
вже офіційно висунули свої кандидатури,
однак існує думка, що вони не мають шансів.
Єдине змістовне рішення в Ризі:
партія AfD більшістю голосів закликає до будівництва
нових атомних електростанцій.
А тепер щодо коронавірусу.
Для дітей та підлітків пандемія була і є важким проміжком часу.
Про це наголошують у
професійній асоціації педіатрів.
Все більше страждає від депресії та емоційних розладів.
Госпіталізація серед підлітків зросла на 40%
в минулому році.
Лікарі висловили вимогу не закривати школи,
навіть зі збільшенням кількості випадків.
Роман Лесковар.
У Якоба Маске зараз багато справ.
Педіатр приймає все більше пацієнтів з
обсесивно-компульсивними розладами
або тривожністю, все це є наслідками пандемії.
Він ще не мав справу з цими хворобами в таких обсягах.
Ми бачимо дітей та підлітків,
які сильно набрали вагу.
Частково за один рік вони набрали від 20 до 30 кг.
Коефіцієнти ваги, які ми не бачили раніше.
Навпаки, ми звертали увагу на дітей, які мають
розлади харчової поведінки
та сильно схудли.
Також багато вчителів
фіксують зростання змін в поведінці.
За даними опитування фонду Роберта Боша,
минулого вересня у 67% учнів помітили
відсутність концентрації.
Зараз це число становить 82%.
Агресивна поведінка зросла майже вдвічі -
з 23% до 42%.
Шкільні психологи б’ють на сполох.
Вони вимагають зняти тиск з учнів на уроках.
Щоб ми почали в школах
більше працювати над взаємовідносинами, емоційною
та соціальною роботою.
Оцінювання, зміст, навчальну програму можна відставити
на другий план.
Інакше ми побоюємося, що це тільки посилиться.
Поза межами школи також необхідно
покращити підтримку,
особливо для дітей з психологічними проблемами,
- вимагають педіатри.
.
Більше терапевтичних місць для
дітей з психіатричними симптомами.
В підтримку своїх пацієнтів Якоб Маске сподівається,
що взимку школи та дитячі садочки не потрібно буде
закривати на тривалий термін.
Навіть якщо кількість захворювань на коронавірус
значно збільшиться.
Британський уряд хоче екстрадувати
засновника Wikileaks Ассанжа до США.
Міністерка внутрішніх справ Пател підписала
відповідний ордер.
Тепер у Ассанжа є 14 днів, щоб подати позов
проти цього рішення.
У США австралійцю погрожує до 175 років позбавлення волі.
Його звинувачують у публікації таємних документів
про воєнні операції США.
Сьогодні всесвітній день боротьби з опустелюванням
та посухою -
очевидними наслідками зміни клімату.
Вони особливо помітні в спекотних та сухих регіонах.
Наприклад, Індійська пустеля Тар в Раджастані.
Літо в регіоні з року в рік стає все більш жарким,
там вже зафіксували аномальну температуру 51°С.
В результаті пустеля продовжує розширюватися.
Нормен Оденталь
Змалку Балнат навчився пасти кіз.
Сьогодні йому 74, він має чотирьох дітей
і жоден з них не пішов його шляхом.
Вони поїхали, бо бути фермером у Раджастані -
дуже важка праця.
На цьому ґрунті не росте трава.
Колись вона була такою високою.
Ми мали достатньо корму для тварин.
Наших запасів вистачало на чотири-п'ять років.
Наразі їх не вистачає навіть на рік.
Якщо Бог дасть, то матимемо,
якщо ж ні, тоді наші тварини загинуть.
Коли говорять «Бог дасть», то перш за все мова йде про дощ .
Але через зміну клімату, дощі тут майже не йдуть.
Температура стає все спекотнішою, а земля менш родючою.
Єдине, що дійсно росте, це територія пустелі.
Пустеля швидко розширює свої межі, а кормових рослин
дуже мало.
Стає все важче врятувати тут екосистему.
Ми робимо все можливе,
поливаємо рослини традиційними методами.
Біля останніх кущів закопують глиняні горщики.
Вода витікає через 20 днів.
Автоцистерна привозить запаси води,
і потрібно знову наповнювати горщик за горщиком,
що надзвичайно втомлює.
Але всі знають, про що йде мова.
Є чіткі докази того, що в цей період посухи, фермери,
які й так були близько до межі бідності,
зараз опинилися за нею.
Індекс бідності та індекс посухи пов'язані один з одним.
Зміна клімату загрожує країні та її народу.
У Раджастані розширюється пустеля, а разом з нею
і хвилювання,
як тут жити далі.
Це не зрівняється зі спекою в пустелі.
Але відповідно до наших даних, ці вихідні будуть спекотними,
температура сягатиме до 40°.
Що це означає і як захистити себе розповість
Крістофер Гайнце.
Балкони та тераси будинку для літніх людей
«Bruder-Konrad-Stifts»
у центрі Майнца у другій половині дня.
Скрізь безлюдно, сьогодні дуже спекотно.
Всередині установи наступний девіз:
пити, пити, пити.
Зневоднення становить особливу небезпеку
для лежачих людей, за таких високих температур.
Крім того, медичний персонал готує
мешканців до спекотних вихідних.
Ми намагаємося рекомендувати людям одягнути щось легше.
Не надто теплі кофтинки та светри.
Вчасно опускати жалюзі, щоб в кімнаті було трохи прохолодно
та робити обідню перерву
трохи довшою.
На вихідних Фрайбурґ
може побити всі рекорди.
В середині червня у Баден-Вюртемберзі
ніколи температура не досягала майже 40°.
Завтра буде особливо спекотно на заході
та південному заході Німеччини,
температура досягатиме до 39°, місцями - 40°,
але це залежатиме від того,
чи потрапить до нас напряму пил Сахари, чи ні.
Якщо ж так, температура трохи спаде.
Такі місця, безумовно, користуються великим попитом
у багатьох частинах Німеччини на вихідних.
Сьогодні численними заходами відзначили
Повстання в Берліні 17 червня 1953 року.
Мер Берліна Гіффі та
федеральна міністерка будівництва Гейвіц
поклали вінки до меморіалу
на кладовищі Зеєштрассе.
69 років тому в НДР відбулися протести,
які радянська армія жорстоко придушила.
Загинуло понад 50 осіб, заарештовано було до 15 тис.
Радість серед німецьких любителів тенісу:
Оскар Отте залишається в грі.
Він сам вважає це неймовірним.
Як і тиждень тому в Штутгарті, Оскар у півфіналі.
А вчора у нього була гра
в Галле у Вестфалії, він програв перший сет
росіянину Карену Хачанову.
Красно дякую усім глядачам.
Глядачі підтримували гру Оскара Отте
в одній восьмій та чвертьфіналі
і зробили можливим його успіх.
Я взагалі почуваюсь добре в Німеччині
і це так близько додому, ще й таке чудове відчуття
потрапити тут у півфінал.
Після програшу першого сету, він дав відсіч
та виграв тай-брейк у другому,
у вирішальному сеті він робить рахунок 3:2 на свою користь.
Через дві години одинадцять хвилин тенісист з Кельна
отримує матч-бол та виконує його з усім потужністю і точністю.
Протягом тижня це другий півфінал
для нового улюбленця публіки в Галле.
Людина росте разом зі своїми цілями.
Завтра суперником Отте стане номер один
світового рейтингу Данііл Медвєдєв,
Ви зможете побачити це у прямому ефірі на ZDF о 14:15.
Баварія з нетерпінням чекає на суперзірку.
За даними різних ЗМІ, ФК «Ліверпуль» дав зелене світло
для переходу нападника
Садіо Мане до клубу-рекордсмена Німеччини.
Сенегалець може дебютувати
у Бундеслізі рівно через сім тижнів.
Команда-чемпіон може зіграти першою.
Після отримання десяти титулів поспіль «Баварія»
має відправитися до Франкфурта.
Минулого разу, коли вони були тут, їм вдалось
вибороти 3 очки,
але тоді «Айнтрахт» не був переможцем Ліги Європи.
Це 15 ігрових днів до Чемпіонату Світу в листопаді.
Національні гравці клубів Ліги чемпіонів
повинні загалом зіграти 26 ігор за 15 тижнів.
Клуби Берліну про це так не турбуються.
В столиці відкриття Бундесліги починається з матчу між
«Гертою» та «Уніоном», і всім клубам, також і «Шальке»,
потрібно щось придумати, щоб скоротити
тижневу перерву в чемпіонаті,
пов'язану з Чемпіонатом світу.
Для деяких це буде стресом, особливо для вболівальників.
Озден Терлі зараз розповість подробиці
про спеку та погоду.
Крістіан Зіверс з нетерпінням чекає на вас в ефірі
«heute journal» о десятій.
Уся команда проєкту «heute о 19 годині»
бажає вам гарних вихідних.
Побачимось завтра.
Гарного вам вечора і ласкаво просимо до перегляду погоди.
Кульмінацію хвилі спеки ми очікуємо вже завтра.
Спека прийде з Північної Африки
через Іспанію, потім від Франції до Німеччини,
ймовірно температура досягатиме до 40°.
У Франції та в Іспанії, а також у Західній Німеччині
вже видно ці прояви.
Вночі на Заході проясниться,
загалом насуваються хмари без опадів.
Опадів не очікується,
на Заході температура буде 19°,
та 10° на Південному сході Німеччини.
Добре провітрюйте приміщення, оскільки завтра
буде спекотно
з великою кількістю сонця,
особливо на Півдні та Сході Німеччини.
В основному хмари майже без опадів.
Щодо температури:
на Південному заході, вона підійматиметься до 39°,
місцями може досягати 40°,
на Півночі температура становитиме від 21° до 24° -
досить стерпно.
В неділю температура становитиме 39°, передусім на Півдні
погода буде сонячною,
в інших регіонах зливи та грози,
ймовірне утворення штормової зони.
Гарного вечора.